breathing from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by quip
listen there's a buzzy gift on
everybody's list this year it's
something they'll use twice every day
and it was featured on Oprah's own list
and it's perfect for everybody would
amount this gift is equipped an electric
toothbrush designed to make brushing
better let me tell you something let me
tell you how this works it works sonic
vibrations gentle enough on your
sensitive gums and a built-in timer with
guiding pulses to remind you when you
switch sides I've been using it since
they sent it to me I am hooked on this
thing you understand me the time it
tells you when to switch are you when
was the last time somebody told you when
to switch and quipped makes how they
travel clean and easy with a multi-use
cover that mounts to mirrors a nun
mounts to slide over the bristles for
on-the-go brushing quip doesn't require
a clunky charger and runs for three
months on one charge what I'm gonna do
this what you're gonna do is this for
the church family all right the reason
why I love quip is well I told you it's
easy to use it works perfect on your
teeth it cleans your mouth and has the
time of the whole thing and that's why I
love quip and that's why they have over
5,000 verified five-star review
now quip looks like a big ticket tech
gift with a stocking stuffer price
starting at just 25 hours and if you go
to get quick comm slash Joey right now
you get your first refill pack for free
free with the quip electric toothbrush
but you don't have to tell you a giftie
that that's your first refill pack for
free I get quick comm slash Joey the
podcast is always also brought to you by
pushy listen it's the holidays you might
get an unexpected visitor and you when
you ass on a be [ __ ] clean and fresh
hello tushy comm makes that easier for
you with portable bidet starting at $69
you can't go wrong there's no reason to
walk around with a dirty ass or no more
go to hell old touchy calm right now and
slash and muffler and
15% off 10% oh I don't know which one it
is it's one of those [ __ ] percentages
take a chance Columbus did and get 15%
off for the holidays a nice you know
what's gonna feel like you know when you
instruct a gyro of 2019 with a clean
[ __ ] that's the first time you've got
a clean [ __ ] so that you were born
your filthy [ __ ]
go to hell well Toshi back home right
now and get 10% off a portal good day
kick that [ __ ] melee I'm
setting on this show first of all it's
ruffle Breeders it's an honor to have
you on the show thank you very much okay
thank you Joey cuz I've been wanting to
be on this damn show uh yeah I just want
to hook up with you when I first bought
houses of the Holy
mm-hmm at the age of 12 or 13 when I
first tried marijuana and dabbled with
it I would put house of the whole yeah
mm-hmm and I would listen to uh uh uh-oh
cuz it's that one another one then it's
no corner dance the ocean yeah I would
skip over no quarter to trippy it was
too much wrongful Joey at the age of 19
it was the devil music I didn't start
listening to no chorus I was like 18
yeah that's when I was when I started
really feeling it it was to strip you
from me and asked a reality by Black
Sabbath yeah bought it brought it home a
little too much from him number of the
beast scared noonas that it scared the
[ __ ] out of me
raised Catholic and I like uh I just get
goose bumps from Vincent prices voice
let me ask you a question because it's
interesting you said you're raised
Catholic so I know you a couple years I
don't know no the Bahji
you know I know your name is Russell
Peters I look at China you're not
Mexican oh you're [ __ ] something
Indian I don't know what it is so boom
you think you're Indian and then today I
just said you know what I don't wanna be
the answer around the guy and shake him
down let me just look him up I lost when
I find that you're from Toronto you know
I didn't know I took you from to use in
some song [ __ ] country I had no
[ __ ] idea and something your family
is white somewhere right some hand glow
Anglo Indian and you're something out
what country are you from India both my
parents this is the funny thing like I
thought Peters
short for like out no I thought that you
said [ __ ] it I'm gonna change it to a
Hollywood no no no you said you went to
she went to a penis but no that's not
the case of you but later on you did do
a movie meet the bathhouse know
something I'd say yeah you got a credit
for it some TV shows think somehow some
movie I probably they probably put my
name on a minute oh yeah no it's crazy
but oh you know what yeah I think I am
in that one so this whole time I'm
thinking shameless Rosalie
Massa Looney [ __ ] whatever that name
is a child Patel and today I find out
this whole different thing that I had
illusions about you you know Russell
Dominic Peters Jesus Christ and you were
raised Catholic raised Catholic you
still go to church now I'm atheist now
now you're an atheist Catholic Church
and you know all the important ones
communion confirmation confession and
then you're like you read the book and
you okay that's how old were you and you
said that's it I'm done I think when I
was a kid and I wouldn't was be in
church and I would look at everything in
the church I'm like this doesn't make
any sense it's really morbid for a kid
to look at this see I thought a couple
years ago I went to church and I saw a
young couple with a child and the child
was unsettled and I said you know what
this is [ __ ] because that was me and
why are you here
my mom used to force-feed me on church
no yeah why was I here my mom was a
whatever fanatic like if you were dead
she would do something for you so after
my father died she would drop in there
like like we'd be in the city and she'd
go let's go see the priest
and we'd drop in and she'd give the
priest like a fifty and a bottle of
scotch yeah and the priest would come
out with my phony casket and put a
ribbon over it and they doing a quick
[ __ ] Mass and I believe that my
father was in that casket was the
creepiest [ __ ] oh yes very morbid
sitting sitting now from a different
angle and looking at it that whole thing
but I gotta tell you man I still believe
yeah I know I don't [ __ ] the pedophilia
[ __ ] all that others have and what
happened because well there's good
sometimes is bad
I still believe this something I talked
about this is Duncan their day I believe
there's something there's a karma force
there's a bull goat at North Karma
something there's something out there
that mace you couple you know just makes
you think about things I actually might
have a theory that I think that whoever
loved you when they were alive when they
died the love can't be broken so ever or
whatever they're doing however they're
there our spirit is there their energy
is moving on or whatever it's doing it
stays connected to you
so are you spiritual on a certain level
you see that I am yeah a certain ritual
ever since I was a kid I always knew my
father was dead but he was always close
to me yeah cuz he loved you as creepy as
it sounds and Mondays on the Cuban
tradition I put our glasses of water I
have an altar for anybody who was my
friend that died I have a picture of him
I put water and why the candle hmm I
pray every Monday for him it's just
something it's called an ancestor altar
mm-hmm because I believe the same thing
I believe they watch over yeah I don't
know why oh it's creepy and as crazy and
you know we work if it works for you
then I say work yeah if it were three of
them [ __ ] it yeah so you grew up in
Toronto grew up in Toronto born in my
favorite [ __ ] city Houston they love
you there dude by Bollywood that moon
what was the name of the club up there
oh yeah coughs no there was another club
comedy wood whether you know I was I was
a Yuk Yuk's guy comedy wood started way
late I started in 89 jiton yeah yeah
Boris Boris the magician Horace
tremendous yeah we weren't allowed to
play there if you played your kicks you
weren't allowed to blink oh yeah they're
different like you have to like sign
like someone had a very low level signed
with Yuk Yuk's right and they can't do
anything other club yeah I don't know if
it's like an actual signature because I
never signed anything but it's just
understood they'd sell to you like look
if you work at Burger King you don't
finish your shift and go work at
McDonald's after you know those like ads
only clubs yuk yuk fat back in the day
they were the largest chain of comedy
clubs in the world
all through Canada all through Canada
they Adam in like Rochester New York and
buff
although the animal on all the border
cities they had them too but that's
subsequently gone we can't control that
mini comedy club ya know especially if
you're not paying people properly no I
started in the late 80s so you know was
like you started comedy in the late
eighteen EIN I started 89 really
yeah laughs AHA then I bump into you
somewhere I was this there I was around
where were you he started in New York I
started in Denver 91 okay went to New
York in 93 for about a tenth month stint
that's it went back to Colorado said
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
mm-hmm back to Colorado develop till 95
went to Seattle met Yoshi Josh wolf
Brody Stephens Brody was out in Seattle
Bay and 95 and then there was
what's-his-name the black comic from
there was Ty Barnett he came later there
was a Daryl Lennox yeah Daryl Lennox was
there because he would always be up in
Canada Daryl Lennox yes Tara Lewis was a
Canadian dude he was guy he was American
but he would always end up in Canada yes
he's the only American I know who got
deported from Canada for staying in
Canada too like I'm like are you in this
business you're in the wrong country
you're hanging out in the wrong country
bro it's crazy how I used to get into
Canada even in the early this like I've
only been to Canada three times all of
the comedy all of them I got snuck in
here legally really before 9/11
you bet haven't been back since no not
even Montreal oh no no they never wanted
me Montreal at all oh they're gonna want
you one time only now they want me but I
can't go there's no way what do you got
there's no I got everything I got herpes
I got gonorrhea I got everything I got a
fucked-up toe you were gonna train New
York there's always that homeless guy
that's got everything
oh yeah he's like a hepatitis C I'm
definitely I got shot a leg just give me
a corner and he smells like piss oh he
smells terrible now in the old days I
used to have a friend in Miami that was
a [ __ ] door guy
he had a Puerto Rican girlfriend I got
along with him a lot and one day we were
talking about Canada she just told me
right
you want to go to Canada or get you into
Canada so I got a call from Roger Paul
yeah and he goes that club wants you to
go up there aren't your client member
rushar Club want you to go up there for
two weeks at comedy wood huh it paid
[ __ ] oh yeah on top of our one week and
you stayed this brothers based up the
other his brother drove hookers at night
he'd wake you up don't know that I got a
hooker
we just got shot she wants to know you
wanna have priceless watch I'm saying
good it's got an extra home yeah but you
know what Toronto was a beautiful
[ __ ] city it's weird how they were
way advanced in 97-98 they already had
delivery service for weed my remember uh
I remember when the the chronic tour
came to Toronto in like 2000 or 99 and I
used to so we backed him and I went and
hooked up Warren G with some weed that
night you would be Jay no I was now I
was still DJ I was doing comedy I was
DJing but I was nice to sell a little
weed to make some money on the side so
he wanted weed knows like I got you I
took him to the weed spot yeah at that
time had a girl that came up to me at
the comedy called the first night she
gave me a number
she was of you got one we they think
it's dirty it's very fine holla
I could be wrong but I one did that the
smoke the weed room the little one right
in Toronto and I'm blanking on the name
but the woman who owns it puff mama told
me that was her probably the calmly at
the comedy club or something like comedy
would I know how many would was up at
Yonge and steals yes yeah young it's
nice to walk over the blonde street boys
floor and that was the best second best
strip club I've been it was the first
best one in Jersey the one that you
could stick a bow I see you go to you if
you go just outside the city in Toronto
you go to a strip joint any anything
goes are you Syrian goes since that
Bloor Street everything what what we
used to do is I when I first started
getting money and I was living here and
I would go home every now and then I had
a
[ __ ] big [ __ ] pocket full of money
I was young at a hard dick and no
[ __ ] dependents so we would go to the
landing strip right by the airport now I
would get all my friends and we would
get the VIP room which is about size of
this place with two couches in it and
there were like eight of us and we get
sixteen chicks in there and it would
call it V Jenga because who's just
Lizzie everywhere in every angle
you know she's sucking off your friend
over there your finger in a while she's
sucking up your friend my friend my
friends making out with this one chick
and squeezing her tits and I'm fingering
her from the back and and he goes so
what's your name she goes Marissa and
get the [ __ ] off me that was his mom's
[Laughter]
oh my god [ __ ] strip clubs what a
disgusting I know now I call them wants
to toots it's it's it's like I got out
of them early like I got in world my
boxing coach took me to a strip cover
the first time in like 87 the night of
the Hagler erne's fight hack no hang
with Leonard fight geez 86 was at 86 86
87 some like yeah my boxing coach took
me and I was I was idle I look like a
child in Toronto yeah it's just outside
of Toronto how old me I was 16 no ID no
no I did not walk did yeah walked in i
sat down and we're gonna watch the
Hagler Leonard fight and he paid the ten
bucks cover to get us in because it was
on closed-circuit TV back then and uh
and I was just I'd never seen naked
women before in my life
I just sat there [ __ ] like completely
amazed this spreadin wide open I was
like this is incredible and then the
they never got the fight so people start
throwing bottles and then riding in the
place but I didn't even notice cuz I
just stared at this [ __ ] gon stay it's
this bottles flying over my head
I don't hear nothing my coach sneaks out
he he leaves to go to another bar to go
watch the fight I turn around there's
barely anybody left in the club I walk
out and they give me $10 on the way out
there getting our buddy the money back
so I got the $10 and I walked back in
the club from the front looked at some
more Posey I got another $10 on
and then I remember I just jogged home
and I remember being so happy and I
remember when I jerked off that night I
could have [ __ ] stuccoed my ceiling
it was in Croydon you leave those plays
Wow you walk home fast oh yeah I jog
like it was no I was about a 3/4 mile
jog but I didn't feel not my dick gets
hard at that age oh yeah see and yes get
you I remember one time I had this in
fact my mother was still alive so I had
to be around 15 14 and add one of those
bag jacks that you know the sperm don't
come out right you got so like something
happen like a chick showed you a tit
blue balls
it's like there's something because my
balls roll up oh I never had that and
know who to ask
I woke my mother up at like 6:00 in the
morning with he would say what do you
want
I'm like mom look at my nuts this is
wrong I mean she's like what is wrong
with you
Jess we're in Spanish huh US current
span oh yeah I'll never forget you used
to sleep with a head he just said in
Spanish why you asked her me am I gonna
because it was dark in the room where
like he can look ahead to and she got up
and she looked at at all weird cuz I
lost everything well he's all open
medical and whatever you said doctor to
me whenever ailment I had one away
yeah you just busted another oh you
gotta say to me his doctor and the
ailment goes away magically it same
[ __ ] friends I don't I don't like
going to the doctor you like my daughter
medicine even at this age I don't like I
thought it will not that go he's a great
guy I love him to death
well I bring an iPod because I think I'm
gonna draw blood I gotta bring an iPod I
get mobile blood draws on my house how
well did one today day : your house yeah
a kind of a house and do it
what do you lay on your bed no I just
sit at the dining table give my arm they
take it and what do they do with the
blood they take it they ship it back to
where they got a ship it to and oh you
got like a physical at the house yeah
why do the I do these like every three
months the mobile blood they come and
take blood Johnny do that just to make
sure I'm all right
so you do the checks you don't do it for
the other reason nah no it's still fancy
I do it for the [ __ ]
changing of the oil and walking mine is
the oil and make new blood that's what
the party starts
I am go sitting over Thor bed you got a
[ __ ] plane taking that and you're
gonna sit the Nova tour bed throws get
some Chinese gotta throw a couple
needles in you hmm
you got some new blood so that's why
women don't die of heart attacks cuz
they bleed every month were the only
[ __ ] that die heart attacks
we don't bleed it out but if we change
that blood every six or seven months
you'd be tip-top Magoo that's why Keith
rich is still alive
yeah what depends we left a lot of
needles in it [ __ ] needles but you
gotta be willing to do that should take
a pint down every 60 days what do they
replace it with new blood no but you do
body forces you you go to Morton's you
get a steak get through chronic mashed
potatoes get the chocolate cake I'll see
you on Wednesday just go home and let
the [ __ ] body recover we didn't get
up in your Starfleet scratch I'm gonna
do that that's how we can only take
little [ __ ] files only two before
these the day you feel it now you feel
like fainting oh now I'm not sensitive
like they put it in the pump they got
the big man they just did did you stick
around you start shooting out Jesus
Christ they find the vein they go after
after Portland I gotta start going down
there baby
December's might kill you insurance
money month that's when a doctor's a
path to December because everybody's
trying to use their insurance money
right so tomorrow I'll call tomorrow
make an appointment for [ __ ] Bob Hope
dope and go down and get my blood taken
he wants to give me a tetanus shot
that's killing me for why would you hurt
yourself no but you gotta take well he
said when you're 50 cuz if not you might
get one nice I read I read one delete
his tweets he said he got a tetanus shot
three weeks ago his arm still hurts that
doesn't help my cause ya know you're
almost 56 yeah that means uncle's you're
six years late I don't know it's me the
prostate at 50 yeah I did it twice
already second time for fun you got to
do it yeah I got two years I'm waiting
yeah no no do it now 148 now when Ross
will go though I'm not rushing in there
it takes five minutes they knock you out
right they don't have to out yes they do
they do
hey they're gonna need to knock you're
going to get in my ass how the camera I
think my just the fire in the ass
me I kept thinking when I said with
knocking me I'm like how they gonna flip
me over this would be tremendous think
of these people Chinese do exactly what
appalled the dog they send you back page
by page of shot by shot of the camera
going in the [ __ ]
you see it start from an inch away they
say they take a camera in there now yes
no more finger it's not a the thing is
the finger you should be getting the
finger now at all do you
48 yeah you should be getting the finger
once a year down they stop doing it for
a reason something happen there's some
sexual act of 1956 but it's been working
since it's a [ __ ] cavemen stick that
finger up my ass doc and one time they
start seeing you with blood needles
and that's me with anything around my
ass home the dog you think I enjoy you
think I enjoy a man who I'm come from
you have to click with doctor tells you
to cradle up in a ball if it was your
ball next thing you know you feel
something go up your ass you leave you
leave there you go you cancel the rest
of the day then you just cancel the
appointment an ex-girlfriend we did a
colonic once and yet we got out of there
we were [ __ ] quiet as [ __ ] in the New
Year no no no I don't believe in nothing
that [ __ ] that that too but my it took
me a lot but I had a friend who was fine
in April she was dead November neesh do
you understand me because she wouldn't
go she was 50 something or something
overweight you gotta go especially with
his life stop today [ __ ] your buddy
call me Eric he's a gay friend I'm
running away and he goes Arby's there's
no hobbies that'll divorced a misty with
a 12-inch black dick but you know that a
Hardee's horseradish that's like black
sperm from the 70s and I didn't pregnant
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes long dong silver GA you
ain't wore that muscle and adjusted and
Arby's oh [ __ ] yes I love the iliad gate
even gang-raped by the Warriors you
[ __ ] done you eat at Arby's they
don't even know what they do anymore
when I was a kid it was roast beef and
that wasn't good
now they got Cuban sandwiches and ham
sandwiches you don't want to go to
[ __ ] Arby's I don't think I've ever
ever craved Arby's in my life
I had no idea you're so against RVs dog
I'm gonna get all that [ __ ]
firehouse John [ __ ] even jerseys I'm
done flying I love war like I like
Jersey Mike's Jersey Mike's is tolerable
but for me I gotta get the numbers and
Jimmy John's
do you like Jimmy John's I'll go to
Jimmy John's they don't have Jimmy
John's where I go I go you know which
one I like that [ __ ] one at the
airport in Chicago those ones they have
in some places they haven't but the
atisan improv across the street I was
just there it's that one across the
street they have them in Chicago is a
sub shop yeah they make like he put the
peppers in it and they haven't met
airports and they run him through an
oven and they have milkshakes where's
now is not Chris Nelson I think crystal
exist know which which no one day I got
one Airport I was starved I was [ __ ]
high as [ __ ] and I know though I don't
trust those [ __ ] that belaying food
mm-hmm and they had one of those places
I'm gonna tell me you make him regular
sandwiches that I can't make your
regular sandwich
done and let me get over to a shape to
boot they made me a vanilla shake at
6:00 in the [ __ ] morning oh I think
I've had this place - yes you have cuz I
had the shake once a in the morn I go
yeah and exactly where was I was I
hadn't slept the main airport in Chicago
yeah yeah yeah it's it's right it's in
the [ __ ] corner of like yes yes yeah
I know the one you walk out there right
down the corner gently got a wide they I
oh they got a tuna fish with
peperoncinis nice but you only doing it
before you go on the plane you can't
take that type of chance
I don't wanna Popeyes Chicken you can't
take that time to chance yeah the other
six hour flight yeah so my ride on the
[ __ ] plane tuna makes you fart well
you don't know what if it's bad tooling
you got on the plane you're sick from
the [ __ ] told her I'm saying it turns
into the movie airplane yeah who had the
fish no he started off in a bags in that
position even in first class it's all
the bathrooms I'm better it's not even
if it's the fur you don't want to be in
that position okay what would you put
yourself in that position that's like
eating [ __ ] sushi from raus before
you get on a plane
it's like eating sushi from Ralph's
anytime anytime you know the saying you
gotta rap you see sushi
I go to Toronto my friends go you want
to go for sushi go there's no ocean
around us where the [ __ ] is this
becoming for others in Toronto well go
eat sushi no there's no why'd you let me
tell what the sad thing is it's probably
really really good fish to get it flown
in every day I don't know I don't know
Canadian we're candidate likes to take a
little shortcuts on that stuff really
yeah the price is too much or keep it
for one more day how's the sushi in
Toronto I don't know I won't go I don't
want to find out really I hear good
things but we live here or I can get
good sushi okay I'm not gonna go there
and what do you eat when you when you
grow up yeah in Toronto what the [ __ ]
were you eat I would enlarge you're
making food which is just like Cuban
food a lot of rice and beans no don't
sit oxtail
love oxtail rice and peas I mean the
[ __ ] jerk chicken all that [ __ ] every
go I don't like go yeah that seems like
a weird one yeah they make curry goat
and I don't like it I like Carrie period
you son of a [ __ ] it's no bad now you
got to get the good stuff you know yeah
you don't like Indian food at all I
don't like even walk it in there what
about buttered chicken no I don't want
to walk in there I don't if I brought
you like the [ __ ] best that [ __ ] I'd
throw it away I was like just taste it
joke I don't know why I swear I hate all
that [ __ ] Thai food no no no I hate
all that [ __ ] coconut milk in my food I
hate all that
I don't mind coconut milk on my side
they don't like carry out with the smell
of it what's the other one cause it's
like at the house tendering arees
no no there's curry is curry this
depends on what meat you put in it when
I was and there's all kinds of different
stuff well that was the roof an
estimated it was Russian there was these
Irish guy Scottish guys and that's all
they [ __ ] ate was uh no yeah cuz
that's all I could get vindaloo own that
[ __ ] spicy chicken vindaloo
they would talk about it and I would
smell in their clothes and I would go
you already had [ __ ] vendor loo place
again when she little [ __ ] I
don't flip my house I was I used to get
mad and they come over what and that
when I was a kid growing up like was a
teenager I would have to do the - like
if my mom was cooking I'd have to make
sure my bedroom door was closed because
I didn't want to get
my clothes I'm gonna go to a club I
don't want to be the [ __ ] Indian guy
that smelled like Indian food so I was
like real paranoid about it so I would I
would time it so I get in the shower run
straight out get dressed and run the
[ __ ] out of a house what couldn't smoke
okay I can't do it there's a lot of
foods I don't eat there's a lot of foods
I don't eat dog really you're very very
finicky very finicky and you never think
it you're like what's your favorite
Cuban food I got a lot of different
Cuban dishes but I'm real picky yet on
the Cuban cause real picky oh my cute
you like your fire Platanos yeah I love
that [ __ ]
I got like and the rice and beans it's
really weird
I've gotten this thing but I like
different things from different places
like when I was growing up if you wanted
to move from wheat then finally Sal I
got a spot don't go on and all the
[ __ ] chicken whatever you know I'm
saying yeah yeah like it's like this one
makes this one good that breaks now I
had it down to a science well then roll
it up in New York well good Cuban
sandwich at night when I get Cuban
sandwich at 3:00 in the morning yeah I
had all that slants down a little more
yeah nobody's got good food at [ __ ]
10 no who's guiding us close there's
nobody's got food but we're getting good
food at an end are you starving after
11:00 a in La Marina Mountains done yeah
you know how many times I've gotten the
Mortons that I've talked to that guy
aren't used to helping toe one and you
keep the [ __ ] bar man you go until
[ __ ] one you know how much I was you
know how many times I'm hungry at 11:00
I'm out the mood for a [ __ ] 16 inch
steak but only three little pieces of
tenderloin with a piece of bruschetta
bread at a bar and have a drink with
four guys I'm gonna do a podcast I would
do that all day long and then Google
Clips whenever I go visit my friend
takes to this place it's like a piano
bar it's like you know it's a real
heavy-duty steak joint but I'm 11
o'clock Russell you go in there get a
shrimp cocktail
you get my carne de tacos they call it
something they charge $18 I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I just want to
be able to eat and watch TV and I get
really hungry at night
that's why I like to talk [ __ ] and eat
you ever do that like talk [ __ ] me but
now you can't do it like you're gonna
Casa Vega at all Casa Vega is down the
block from yeah yeah yeah sunset there
Nona Ventura every once in a while they
got a dark in there that's my beef with
my beef in there is that you don't know
I think I'm gonna [ __ ] I think I'm
gonna [ __ ] in looks like an old mob
movie and they're naughty yet to come
one of those I think I'm man on fire and
he's gonna come out from hiding and
shoot me in the [ __ ] head Denzel why
you can't even look at the menu in there
it's [ __ ] dark yeah and then it got
closed for a health violation yeah yeah
I don't mean to throw a little no no I
mean uh my assistant goes there
religiously so I said hey they closed
her for a rodent infestation is that
what it was and he goes now they had
like a little mice bar like like
whatever I don't care
listen let me explain something to you
when I go into a place and you got a B
we can't do business and I'll tell you
why because you gotta be a [ __ ] to
fail that test you gotta be a [ __ ] to
fail that test it's not like a [ __ ] if
they don't walk in they tell you they
call you and they tell you we're coming
down in six weeks you got six [ __ ]
weeks efficient forgiving and you still
fail sometimes you gotta read between
the lines because sometimes you fail for
stupid [ __ ] yeah like the temperature on
the wall that wasn't hotter than four
there's always some in fracture there
but we yeah I can't I can't deal with
that they tell you they're gonna come
how can you not have an A rating see I
don't know my parents are from a
third-world country so when I go to
India as a kid I would eat on the street
that didn't bother me well you got a
stomach of a billy goat I do but I did
get sick when I was there last time
oh [ __ ] yeah but I wish we were shooting
a TV show and we were shooting in the
slums and the biggest slum in the world
and it was like [ __ ] I mean you see
rats this big just running through the
tricks of piles of trash everywhere just
people living amongst piles of trash
like big [ __ ] positive what it
Russell Peters decide to eat food so
what happened they at nighttime when it
gets dark all these vendors show up and
they turn on their
deep front like they have hot oil and
and everything smells fantastic and I'm
like [ __ ] it smells so good I'm like
it's being cooked right in front of me
it's hot I mean how [ __ ] dangerous
can this be well I found out Joey how
dead what him [ __ ] him
I had the trots for two weeks what did
you know I was eating whenever the guy
was cooking right beside me oh it taste
a good going in well how is it helped me
lose weight going out when I was a kid I
had a bunch of friends that right from
high school they got a hot hired at a
place called on chemical what we called
hot chemical hmm chemical you know you
wanted and you breathed whatever in
those days nobody had a mask on right
and they paid you good money but the
clinker was that you signed up to travel
that was the thing but the first stop
they took you to the test your
willingness was India really and all of
them quit I can get you and they all
came back with horror stories and these
were Jersey boys that were tough the one
asked him over the one guys story that
he moved in he went to work and when he
came home when he pulled up his car he
couldn't count how many rats were in
front of his house like they would just
scatter it you guys picked the right
place to learn said he one of the
chemical put him in there well then they
[ __ ] he said he went upstairs he's got
his luggage and he went to the airport
he didn't make the [ __ ] day I guess
don't remember that story now don't let
none of that stuff you could get some of
that out there you want me to tell you
something bro I want to shoot a movie in
Jamaica right between you and me I made
them fire me on purpose
yeah because I couldn't eat that food at
the hotel did they not have you at a
five-star it just it was I just could
not eat the whole hotel the chickens on
when I was driving to the hotel you see
the chickens on a string on the street
that's why I don't eat meat in India
listen to me dog like I can't go
internationally well between you and I
there's reasons because I would drive
people crazy I don't like a lot of stuff
I watched that one [ __ ] on TV the one gay
guy that goes you can swap them ball
sperm and all that dude they all say
wrong and they catch a fish out of the
ocean eats the eyeball that's Andrew
Zimmern that guy you better pay him
every dollar he [ __ ] deserves the
bald guy right cuz yeah I would need
half this [ __ ] easements yeah and I'm
not like I'm not playing the [ __ ]
guessing game I mean [ __ ] it eats
everything I can well that was a kid
what's that bird Guinea Guinea took
their guinea fowl guinea fowl used to
they use them for Santeria things yeah
yeah I had the real rituals but after
would you cook it needed I wouldn't even
touch that type of chicken like that
brown skinned chicken I don't like oil
either my mother would go nuts
I don't like whale I don't like pigeon
none I don't like [ __ ] I don't like
[ __ ] [ __ ] Duncan
I don't read dunk I don't like nothing I
like chicken beef Lobster
Torian [ __ ] what's before I'll [ __ ] this
important well yeah I won't look at the
cook animation look at the cook we have
some cooks of the savory in Addison
Texas one time I worked hyenas and the
other they used to be two hyenas this
was the dirty I eNOS now Fort Worth but
the other one and there was a guy
outside bigger than Ralphie May 600
pounds that's old pork chops for a
dollar one Wonder Bread his hands were
filthy let me tell you something like
six pork chops and I went home I'm sure
you have three more that guys there were
that good with the ball in them and he
put them on a piece of bread you prefer
egg hot sauce on it you have no idea
that grill that been cleaned in years
yeah that's what I say the dirty of the
joint the better the food joint the
[ __ ] food sometimes it's more
marinated yeah well that's what I'm
gonna say about be I don't go in for
like a chain the only thing I'll do with
some Asian food like Chinese food like
that's what I learned when I moved out
here that some Chinese food is okay
where'd you move from Boston hmm listen
if there's a bad restaurant this guy
will pay no I rested there's a bad
restaurant
he will pick it up just on purpose just
on purpose what kind of bad restaurant
see like I don't he told me that when I
got a career trying to get dumplings
that all of its cat yeah I don't [ __ ]
with that [ __ ] aha
thank you thank you but there's Koreans
in there I don't give a [ __ ] well what
they are I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
extremist to it listen like I told you
last night while we're doing it with
whatever his [ __ ] name was when I got
a chance dragon in I know there's mice
I'm eating somebody's cat I know I might
beat somebody's dog but I go in there
with the understanding you go in there
thinking like they're all Anthony
Bourdain ain't there that don't mean
nothing somebody's cat is [ __ ]
missing Shane [ __ ] Silverlake and
you're eating the [ __ ] thing you
don't even if you take the shell off
that dumpling you will not know what's
in that meat its mystery me it is great
it's like eat the hot dogs gray meat
it's a heat in a long time
you're taking your chances where you
either from ah that's the story I get it
maybe I maybe I just trust people too
much but I can't playing some of them
poor cat there was everything in there
there's a thing called filler Lee filler
huh the only thing about filler whether
you [ __ ] do coke or [ __ ] whatever
this filler they got a dope to [ __ ]
dish up
talk to him will you please Russell
Peters a little man where do you go for
Indian food then where should I go that
like Indian food Indian food I can't I
am found the right place out here there
used to be a place right down the road
in the in Studio City called the great
India cafe and then they changed the
name I don't know if the food's still
the same but they change the name it's
right next door to a porn shop on
Ventura
before lemonade in Studio City before
before you get to Jerry's okay same side
across the street closest what do you
get you get the chicken tikka masala
okay first you get a chicken biriyani on
the order excited chicken tikka masala
then when your biryani comes you take
the chicken tikka masala gravy and you
pour it all over your biryani
you'd like biryani it's just fried rice
basic it's just rice with chicken baked
into it it's pretty damn good
well you put that [ __ ] gravy on it
you're taking it to another level okay
I love it I think Joey might like that
no just just the just the [ __ ] look
on his face was the best thing you're no
[ __ ] idea you have no idea I have one
day guy wanted to meet with me like a
[ __ ] script dude and they called me
they kept telling me they were gonna
meet at one place
that's the last one I got attacks that's
when kind of text our pager and I pulled
over they told me that they were meeting
at that place around the corner from toy
no toy I'll go into what's annoying like
toy I'll go in there and get the Pad
Thai shrimp
I don't know that Thai shrimp it's on
sunset it's open till 4:00 oh well you
got to take your shoes off right they
don't like that either right thing that
they'll take your shoes off
yeah I think I'll filthy white people no
not Hollywood
I'm not gonna eat [ __ ] Thai food and
then smell bad feet at the same time so
what what happened with that page what
page you had the page from them saying
they changed the restaurant they changed
the restaurant to a [ __ ] curry
restaurant and I thought I wasn't going
they could not understand that I would
not send one I can't smell that stuff it
drives me crazy
yeah Ethiopian food all that [ __ ] now I
won't read the opium food recently I
didn't no no no no no even that you're
making stuff cuz I love Jamaican food no
the jerk chicken that you'll make my
[ __ ] bleep I know that [ __ ] love this
[ __ ] oxtail is my favorite oh my god
still how my mom made well my mom died
must make it as to like a brown stew no
she made it like she chopped it yeah I
was not gonna stew and it's really
tender and got my god she made it real
tender and you had Frank's hot sauce no
matter how old I was
she let me drink a little bit of low
brow with it she made white rice with
red beans with those [ __ ] oxtail and
I'd pour the hot Frank's hot and some
cool tails off and it was [ __ ]
brilliant yeah
iced I could taste her in my mouth my
girlfriend just made it for me recently
and she made it incredibly she'd
Jamaican nope
Honduran oh yeah yeah they're ghost
aroma [ __ ] she made it she
never she never made it before in her
life I just told us what I like and she
figured out the
really and she made the rice and beans
perfect real and I'd you making my
Jamaican friends for Toronto we're at my
house at the time they're like yo you
sure she's not [ __ ] Jamaican this [ __ ]
is incredible
that's good together the first try
oh my god she bought the big oxtails i
Gigan [ __ ] big chunks of meat she
didn't buy the little [ __ ] ones
gonna get the little [ __ ] ox tails
she bought the big [ __ ] Russell
Peters you don't [ __ ] around Dave no
it's not [ __ ] around here Joey I read
you I read your inspirational quotes
every [ __ ] morning it's time to wake
up and grab life by the balls and kick
it in the [ __ ] you [ __ ] you gotta get
them going
not if I tell myself are important so
why not spread the [ __ ] really when I
go you know what he's right
you know it's [ __ ] up what you feel
like in the boy you know like what the
stages of your life what you felt like
when you were a kid you ready to wake it
up for a while no I still hate it then
you get up because you had a watch
cartoons in a certain time mm-hmm
then you you know the summer will come
and then you have you were forced to get
a job like Ivan one of my first [ __ ]
jobs was getting up at 3 in the morning
when I was around 8 maybe 7 to go get
flowers in New York City my stepfather
had a side business shop and we would
get up at 4:00 maybe 4:30 and the sum is
4 3 times a week that was brutal
I had to deliver newspapers on the
weekends Saturday and Sunday edition in
my neighborhood I'd have to wake up
[ __ ] like 5:00 in the morning because
you'd have to put them together
yes yeah because they would send you the
inserts earlier in the week so you get
the entertainment section and the TV
Guide and then they would deliver the
[ __ ] the front page and everything
that that morning then you'd have to get
up put it all together and then deliver
it so people can have for their morning
breakfast house 11:00 12:00 Iran then
and you hate again not [ __ ] hate it
what time you get up now as late as
possible 5 really yeah if I can get up
around should have I can get out of bed
2 o'clock I'd be very
be with that but I'm up around noon now
what time do you go to bed I try to go
to bed early but I almost [ __ ] it up
somehow
sometimes I'm trying to jerk off on a
KAG I'm not gonna sleep til I get that
nut like in 4:13 one of those thing off
still trying to get at it and you watch
TV and I know not even you turd I go on
the reader i watch watch a lot of
science [ __ ] on the computer do you have
insomnia boy
no no I can fall asleep I just something
stupid inside me goes no no hold on this
is gonna miss something stay awake for a
second and I wake myself back up and the
minute I wake myself back up or I'll
fall asleep nice quick and easy
perfectly and I have a laptop open then
I'll just open my eyes to close laptop
and that's it I'm awake again now when
you do your world tours you get up at 12
also when I'm on tour I would do I wake
up as ladies but if it's show 2l I won't
leave my hotel room I'll wake up around
3:30 4 o'clock and then I'll be alright
I'm fresh for the show good and what
time do you go to bed the night before
no 3 2 3 you know when does your next
tour start I'm still on - I just got the
month off so I get back out on the road
in January and what is this tour take
you how far these are [ __ ] crazies of
the world working well we start back in
America January February and then late
February we head out to the Middle East
and India and then May so late February
March April I'll be in Middle East and
India and then in May I'll do Africa and
July or June and July I'll do some more
American dates nothing could pack it in
that's it taping my new special in March
we're at in Mumbai India no [ __ ] never
been done so I'm gonna do it [ __ ]
tremendous Russell fees they got - it's
never been done I want to be the first
guy to walk on that moon good for you
but what is Mumbai India like I love
it's one of my favorite cities New
York's my favorite and Mumbai is my
second what is it like what's the appeal
of it I don't know it's just alive you
know it stinks sometimes
like what it depends on what time of
year it is could smell like [ __ ] cuz
there's an ocean right there and
sometimes the fishermen have just pulled
in a big haul and it's so hot and humid
dead [ __ ] City smells like content
[ __ ] but I love it drugs
nah not really it's not it's a detail up
all off strip clubs what's that there's
everything everything is there if you
want it food is incredible there what
kind of food it's Indian food you know
but everything's good there I mean it
but beef is now illegal they've made
beef illegal and in Mumbai so you can't
order be for the restaurant can't get it
what's gotta be like yeah basically is
like beef dealers where do you want
warrant cow I got it
you want one ounce two what is
population of Mumbai Indian Mumbai's
population is about can you figure this
one out
and how big from paracin well India's
population is 1.3 billion right that's
ones there and in Mumbai is one of the
biggest cities if not the biggest thing
you've done comedy there before yeah and
it's just been a tremendous it's been
always amazing for me I always manage to
get in trouble when I'm there like for
my mouth I say something you know they
asked me about something and I just tell
them as I see it or hear it and then I
used to people who were like in the
spotlight being honest and real so it
kind of throws them off guard
do you speak Indian no I understand I
understand most of it I would say I
understand about 60% I think I
understand more Spanish how big is
coming in India now it's now very huge
he's now is very big when I first
started going over there well it didn't
exist I was the one and then YouTube
I think it's 22 million that's it that's
what I'm saying yeah but that's in one
city yeah just in Mumbai yeah what's
next to it another place I don't know
somewhere else and this Mumbai theatre
no it's I'm gonna do yeah there's an
indoor arena I did an indoor stadium and
then I did an outdoor one once
yeah throne was a trip though because we
had
have fans blowing at me the whole time
because of the insects because the
lights attract all the insects and you
would look and the [ __ ] it would just be
like to be covered with insects just
swarming at the light and then I would
need the fans on me to blow them away
from me so that they wouldn't [ __ ]
get in my mouth while I'm doing my show
my show yeah big [ __ ] fans and I felt
like Beyonce on stage my [ __ ] clothes
are blowing away and but she it's
necessary when they were setting up that
gig it was funny a wild boar right
through the [ __ ] wall the cellar
setting on the the chasing his wild boar
through this field
daddy's crazy you know I love how the
[ __ ] you doing Ross when they do the
field it makes you nervous cuz there's
[ __ ] snakes out there there's Cobras
there's pythons there's all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] you know what head crawling
up on you while you're [ __ ] doing it
somebody sitting up there and during the
zone BAM you know that is crazy
if you thought these do you thought a
[ __ ] show at Oceanside was ours
yeah we were Samoans throw a knife at
you [ __ ] like this a wild boar and wild
boar running through we have a picture
but somewhere I should send it to you
one day when I find it and when you got
a 12th you go in Africa Africa we're
doing South Africa Kenya I think we
might do Tanzania we're gonna be doing
Nigeria possibly Ghana and you've done a
leave before no I've only done South
Africa and Kenya before I did Djibouti
years ago with the USO Christ okay get
out there man it's a big world we live
in Joe and if you weren't so goddamn
finicky I'd take you with I was scared
I'm scared show us it's crazy how
finicky I am in these hotels I'm telling
you in these other countries like in
these so-called third world countries
they're [ __ ] 5-star hotels are better
than anything you've ever seen here food
spotless tidy everything service service
incredible incredible yeah we don't know
that about customer satisfaction no no
these
phone call different less the block yeah
I had a butler in one of my Suites in
Mumbai that cuz I had a suite so they
give me a butler and I wouldn't see him
I would be like looking I go [ __ ] did he
call and I would just black my crew when
I would be sitting there go you want to
go eat lunch and they're like yeah let's
go eat lunch and then and then before I
could even say his name he just pop out
of nowhere like Shelley I go to the
vision and you're like yeah what the
[ __ ] were you pretty wild
like in deep mr. deeds member mr. Diaz
show up out of nowhere wasn't it John
Turturro yeah it was John Stehr oh yeah
that's crying crazy do all those great
cities how long is the flight
um probably 20 hours
he's break it up you go I usually go LA
to Dubai Dubai to whoever I need to go
to cuz I fly with Emirates fly Emirates
first class he's gonna change your life
no [ __ ] they have a shower and throw a
shower in first class the bathrooms
about the [ __ ] size of this room in
first class for yourself
face off Yugo in the bathroom Yu I get
buck-ass naked floors heated [ __ ] it you
can stretch out you know I mean it's
fantastic Jesus Christ how long is the
flight to Dubai flight from here to
Dubai is about what maybe 14 hours let's
see nothing and you you actually don't
want the flight to be any shorter cause
he'd be like uh-huh as fantastic you got
a bed
you got a door on your suite they give
you pajamas ordered whatever you want
whenever you want they give you the menu
go let's let us know whatever you want
whatever you want we'll make it for you
and the food's fantastic and you fly
right into Dubai flying to Dubai go into
the lounge you take another shower if
you want and then Dubai you connect the
Indian all those yes amazing
you just feel live your own [ __ ] life
Russell it's fantastic you know I have
on tour with me in Canada just now is
Jason Collings
he was killing it you know Jason yes yes
hilarious she just finished a Canadian
tour just finished canal how long was
the Canadian three weeks how many nights
a week it was every other night
then on the last week was like five in a
row Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Christ yeah and yet before can type by
that day oh yeah you're good but there
was something I have by the second last
show I skipped the whole chunk out of my
act because I wasn't sure if I'd done it
or not that's what happened to give you
two shows of one night not even but it
was like back-to-back show so it was
like ah [ __ ] today oh it was the next
night but I was like and then I look at
my DJ's on stage I looked at him and
they looked at me like you forgot
something I was like okay good then I
just put it at the end and you're on
stage with the details
yeah I got my two DJ's on stage who DJ
yeah one plays instrumentals you other
one plays acapellas and they mix
together live they don't practice they
just do it the jam they just jam up
there and then you walked in do your
thing yeah
for how long hour-and-a-half I do an
hour twenty Jason goes up to 20 I do an
hour 20 hour and a half sometimes I mean
you're on the road constantly you don't
go back home no I just guy acts came
home Wednesday and I'm leavin again
Thursday that's what we do what we do
Joe crazy what we do see how long you
been doing comedy about a year it's what
you will do yeah I've been doing a
twenty seven years yeah I [ __ ] nine
years ago seven years ago I was just
gonna quit it comes that point at all
every time we're just gonna do local
comedy act and go on the road to broke
that was blank plan that was it I didn't
want to go to the funny bone everyone
don't know that [ __ ] I didn't well do
all the Rogen states but I don't mind
doing a couple of them some of them were
fun in my first introduction to you it
was the Longest Yard really yeah and I
was like wow and I I thought it was like
some past door yeah everybody okay like
a big [ __ ] in this and then I say Joey
Diaz wait a minute that's Joey Diaz cuz
I had heard your name I hear Coco Diez
and I was picturing a little guy here
Coco you think ammo guy no
no I was Copa because of the color of my
skin I was so white when I was a kid
right
then paid for the rest of my family said
I was white like the inside of a coconut
ha
so the name stuck and the rest is
[ __ ] history my ex-girlfriends father
was Cuban she's Cuban this I was doing
but she was only identified with the
Cuban side and his name growing up was
the [ __ ] was his name cuz he had blue
eyes and blond hair yeah they call you
Julio please Diana come Rubio ho Allan
Rubio where were they from Miami now
from from I hear from the valve of the
valley yeah
you're a [ __ ] animal of a guide dog
and all this started out what did the
sensation start started in 2004 I did a
special in 2003 that aired in 2004 so
2000 from February 2004 uh uh what were
you doing family at that 15 years 15
years yeah so I uh I do the show at
DePaul University on in February of 2004
eleven people come they pay me 700 bucks
and I'm thinking [ __ ] it's a lot of
money I feel bad you know but I did the
show I did did the did a good show they
enjoyed it and then the special aired
like that night in Canada somebody
recorded it and started file-sharing it
like I'm bear share or LimeWire you know
and that kind of [ __ ] and all the file
sharing rooms and started getting cut up
into bits of like here's him doing
Jamaicans here's him doing Indians
here's from doing Chinese here's some
doing this and then it would just get
chopped up and sent to the people who
I'd be talking about so then you cut to
November of 2004 I go back to Chicago
and I sell out three nights at some
theater and I made like 40 grand and I'm
like the [ __ ] just happened I was just
here like nine months ago and I couldn't
sell a [ __ ] I couldn't give a ticket
away and I knew something was happening
and then in 2000 you know 2005 YouTube
starts and then my ship ends up on
YouTube and it was over from there
and I still to this day don't know who
did it I don't know who put it on there
ain't that trippy and they tell you
here's the part that you can appreciate
my dad died March 2004 and right after
my dad died is when all the file-sharing
started and I mean that's so it's like
some like I said the people that love
you I think they could pull a string or
two on the other side you know what I
mean like I just you know they see you
coming and they just gotten out under to
this Franco this way you know they don't
do much they just kind of just push it
over so you end up they're going in the
right direction but from YouTube to
sound out the h2o in Toronto the it was
the Air Canada center then the
Scotiabank Arena right like how does
that [ __ ] map I sold about seven
times now I'll show you the I'll show
you the picture you'll like this you
know follow me on instagram Joe I don't
like the bot nut you know me dog this
was two weeks ago
and that's how many people ditch 115
thousand 15 so this last time you did
that we show that you're doing just one
just one the first two times I did the
Air Canada Centre I did it two nights in
a row twice and then scaled back then to
one one and then another one now so
still what's every time every time
you're at the Comedy Store today in the
main room it is 450 people in there no
no and you've just done 15,000 that's
Saturday night what are you feeling in
your head what are you feeling this time
I was very relaxed all the other times I
was nervous I was in my head you know I
don't want to diss that I was very
relaxed this time I was always
questioning my material before this can
be good enough is that gonna be good
enough and now I'm like very confident
with it it's like I know I got a good
product and I know you're gonna like it
so [ __ ] it let's just do this are you
one of those guys that write stays home
for six months no make it on stage and
just spit until I like it
and then once you have an hour then you
take it out yeah okay I'll go do a club
run when I'm trying to write I'll go do
like [ __ ] three three weekends six
six a six or eight shows a weekend with
nothing and then by the end of the thing
I've got about 25 30 minutes so what
club you go to whatever I'll go to play
I go to places where it doesn't like
where I don't usually go so I'm out of
my comfort zone you know you got to be
uncomfortable you need to be
uncomfortable to make yourself
comfortable I believe with all that yeah
I believe in all that stuff you're not
gonna like not not they're not bad rooms
by any means I'll go to Charlie good
nights to start writing there you know I
could have like places where so I don't
really give a [ __ ] if you're there
you're not gonna really sell out these
places you know and I mean really you'll
have a hard time so no I mean I sell
them out but like it's not guaranteed
that's crazy yeah I don't want the easy
I don't like the easy road it's not then
you don't learn anything that way what
do you mean by the easy road I mean
going where you know you're gonna kill
what are you gonna learn
it's like training with guys you know
you can beat what's the point you're not
getting better you're just just doing
what you know I mean you got it you got
to challenge yourself all the time
when I first got here I was very lucky
that the first month I became a regular
at the store but like everybody else you
have to do spots everywhere else yeah
you have to go the in program to the
Laugh Factory have to go to the Mexican
bar and Silverlake you get one of the
Mexican place and biking taco off the
five oh yeah but then you find where you
specialize it so you did though Comedy
Works in Denver them back then right I
started the time he works in debt yeah
that's a the downtown club first I love
that Club first time I got on stage that
the Comedy Works in Denver and then I
pursued it and then I got banned for
life some of the comedy works and that's
what made me leave Colorado now then I
would and anyone no no I'm not bad but
it was funny because I bumped into her
and we spoke from the heart like I
hadn't spoken to her since the banning
she was at a manager she Wendy was the
older design hmm and I didn't get banned
I got banned because of her if it wasn't
we going to you and going Joey grabbed
my ass right it was you going to me and
going hey I saw Joe Rogan gravely SAS
there that then when they called the
girl to go because I don't know if he
grabbed my ass and that you know we were
all drinking the manager pushed it and
they said you know what let's just
abandon that was the easy thing it was
the best nectar that happened hmm
in retrospect oh yeah where I was at
that point I was two weeks away from
getting arrested yeah in retrospect if
you really look at it I was six months
away for going to jail for ten years I
was about to do something stupid I
didn't know what it could be anything it
could have been driving weed cocaine in
the car it could have been me stabbing
my ex-wife's boyfriend he could have
been of the range of things and she came
to me and said you're banned from me and
I had two options I had the two other
clubs which no disrespect to total
garbage at the time right you were
would [ __ ] and then there was another
club in Colorado Springs that wasn't
burned down the house either so I said
at least let me go to a market where
there's a good club for me it was the
comedy underground Seattle have to talk
no I was a good that's gone to run club
a lot of people Mitch was there right
Mitch was there a lot of people Stanhope
was did a lot of people up there that's
a great place and they used to book a
lot of San Francisco
so she's just glad a great comedy pool
oh yeah so you were featuring four great
people when you updated also did you
work with Jake Johansen back then I have
not worked with Jay you know I took Jake
on tour with me on this tour as well no
you did not sure did I took him into
Australia I took him to Asia I took him
to the best writers your room he's
amazing one of the best comics in the
game yeah you know what a lot of
comedians don't understand that one time
you're gonna be very relevant yeah then
there's other come a time when you're
not relevant anymore yes not because
you're not funny
yeah it's just because the tides aren't
with you anymore
yeah there's nothing you could do you're
always gonna have your fifty to a
hundred per show diehard fans
right but that mania that was once one
day is no longer gonna be there
most guys quit most guys have nervous
breakdowns I'd talk to Jake via phone
one day in fact we spoke about him come
along the podcast oh yeah you lady wants
to do it he training jiu-jitsu now - is
he training with annatto I did really I
was down there a couple weeks ago ya
know I got him into it I he was asking
me about it and I said yeah you got a
you should just do it
you're gonna love Jake's a great comedy
writer let me tell you something I
learned a lot he's phenomenal from
watching that guy you watch that guy and
it's like a knife cutting through butter
that's the way to describe his comedy
yeah it's like a hot knife cutting -
does he still have the record for
Letterman appearances he probably does
he does he I used to tape him you too
I usually would tape and I used to watch
him I was a fan I was like 5 I was
watching why but the
how many words I think I paid to watch
him yeah Rogan always says he paid to
see Sam I think I paid to see Jake
Johansson when I was still an open mic I
paid to see Eddie Murphy in 86 and Chris
Rock and in 2000 and Carlin III in our
panel I paid to see some people now you
a tight with garlic know you better I
met him twice in my life where did you
bump into him it first time was in
Toronto in 1992 when the Blue Jays had
won the World Series we doing comedy I
was doing comedy I was three years in
the wedge your book men talk everybody
was partying up and down the street
Yonge Street in Toronto I was 22 I was
like a punk-ass kid and I'm walking I've
been down the street every was having a
great time and I see this old guy with a
ponytail walking towards me and I'm
being a smartass look at my friend go
holy [ __ ] sky looks like George Carlin
and he walks past her how you doing
George I'm just being a dick how you
doing George and he goes hey don't kid I
was like holy [ __ ] and I ran after it
what's really am I walked him back to
his hotel i gushed over I'm like oh man
it's and if you want Indian food my mom
will cook for you anything I get
anything and I said he gave me his
autograph he gave me some advice and
then he said I said hey maybe one day
we'll work together good yeah you never
know kid this crazy [ __ ] business and
then I work with him ten months before
he died we're at comedy magic club I got
the host he was getting set he was
getting his new set together for HBO did
you remind them I told I told the whole
story when I introduced him I got all
glassy-eyed
all chili quivered and it's horrible
what's our God like that do that type of
[ __ ] I yeah I was [ __ ] so emotional
and I cried when he died you have to
yeah you have to well it's not a lot of
people but you know some people get you
they do they really do like imma being a
Kindle and I can't wait I could never
imagine a world without child Bronson
like when Charles Bronson died life I
can cry like wait two minutes yeah it
was no big [ __ ] deal shut it tear
like well then watch Rocky and he wins
at the end man I shed a tear
you know just cuz you get emotionally
it's I got sucked in today at the pool
today I took the kids to the pool over
at the pool I thought about something
and my wife looked at me she caught me
wiping my eyes she goes what is it now
hey you know that as we get older we get
more [ __ ] sentiment no I've always
been one of those dude really III try to
fight it
I hate when it happens like you know
like a fight like when a fight happened
I'm watching boxing like remember when
Bernard Hopkins one became the oldest
person to win a title I think was like
40 45 or 46 when he won like a light
every way title he beat Tito something
no Beatty knows before that but he and I
remember crying when he won I was like
if I don't even know Bernard I don't
know I'm crying I just was overwhelmed
for him I was like what a great moment
in life it's you know it's we what makes
me cry today they it's the weirdest
thing
yeah it's not things I was supposed to
make you know it's like happy moments
make you cry like seeing somebody win
makes me cry like I have but it's not
sad it's like I'm happy for them
I get overcome with emotion the worst is
when you think you're going to cry out
and you don't and then you start
doubting your love or whatever have you
ever had that situation not even ten
days ago one of my all-time favorite
cats died who his name is Jimmy I had a
cat cat actual cat one of the catching
crop worth over 14 years he was just a
smart devious little douchebag of a cat
like he was just a [ __ ] skull of cats
too I love just love oh [ __ ] with all my
heart and I got home from New York and
as I was hauling the luggage I looked at
him on the couch and I knew because the
whole time his brother had been sick his
brother's got cancer but his brother's
been gaining weight we got him back on
steroids
the brothers as tough as nails I kept
saying you know what I hate for it to be
the seat because if Harry goes dead
they're litter mates mm-hmm you go
Demi's gonna lose his mind the whole
time I'm thinking about Harry I get back
from New York I tell my wife there's
something wrong with Timmy he's getting
[ __ ] fat
and my wife touched him and he me out we
knew something wasn't right the next day
he did once they start hiding you know
it's not good huh so he took him to the
valve to his day and they said he was
really a bad shape well luckily we
brought him we did he was having
problems breathing and that day I got on
my hands and knees with him on the floor
you know his back was to me he was he
was so proud and he wanted to die in
peace that he went in the cage at first
like he didn't want nobody the same in
that Chang the cats didn't want to be
around them he finally came on his own
but I kept talking to him and he came
closer to me and I started told it from
toddler come talking home just saying
how good of a cat you were you're my
friend I made a nice like I'm home
I smoked pot with it and then we played
that stupid game but at one point he
wasn't moving like he was just staring
onto the abyss and he was breathing
heavy yeah he was puffing and I said
something to him bro and he turned his
head towards me like that way for me the
kisses had I kissed my Crabill but I got
up I said goodbye and my wife put him in
the cage she cried all the way to the
car and I was hit my cry a little bit
later and two days later I was like I
didn't cry enough I'm like that's
[ __ ] when you see people cry real
fast as [ __ ] because nobody you're
in shock yeah you don't even realize it
though he's dead three months that's
when it really hits you yeah when my
mother didn't hit me for five years four
years how old were you when that
happened sixteen
oh damn and I went off the rails at 21
oh I mean it was two different worlds
the realization that you're not gonna
see anybody again hmm
you know today I went to call you and I
when I popped up Rafi
I still have phone number in my phone
yeah same you know you know you as a
human being that dead but they're still
alive in your heart that roughly would
stay at my house in Malibu when you
would come back yeah yeah and I still
have his number in here
like it has they would hit me in my
world he's plowing on the road yeah when
Ralphie why not somebody told me about
Ralph had called him I don't know [ __ ] I
was I was just hoping he would answer
you know
well we always do that yeah I was like I
might answer the phone please
every time I hear somebody dying I
called him please answer I think I
called them to let me know this isn't
real ooh she called my call name a
Patrice I was like please answer the
phone Patrice call me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
or something you know I mean tell me I'm
not funny do something that you do yeah
that's I don't think your mind like I
saw the video and I hate bringing this
up because it's really bad but the video
of the black kid that got shot
Mississippi the mistake mmm the guy that
was a soldier what the mall the one who
stopped yeah a shooter and then got shot
when they had the press conference it's
always the fat black lady who faints why
do always fat black people always faint
there was a person I think that's
pressure
did you she just fainted like six black
dudes trying to hold all of them
tarzan's
and not one of them could hold this one
but I'm very him she had a little bomb
[Laughter]
why black people always afraid they're
in the funeral
I'm funerals nobody ever fainted the
others I am oh my god I hate [ __ ]
funerals I hate all that [ __ ] because
that's what the real faultiness comes
out yeah well my mother died I learned a
big experience so those four days cuz
there was a Cuban funeral
so they keep you alive in the casket for
four days they just keep throwing
[ __ ] that the smile behind mouth
behind us time you have to maintain you
so you know something I don't bury the
arm pops up yeah I think they break the
redid you know that they've got to break
your spine what they break your spine
during the [ __ ] in whatever so you don't
pop up in there or whatever yeah oh wow
I didn't know that part
well Jews go in the next day huh Jews
going immediately well in like 24 hours
they go they get burnt
Barry yeah Muslims - really hey you guys
are the same okay
yeah they'll keep you in the room for a
week yeah until you start kicking
ranking and doing food and one of my
skype hangout on put your food in your
[ __ ] casket when they pick my mother
up there was next 100 pounds of bottles
like her they kept putting bottles of
pinch in there she probably got Barry
would help you to a coke I'll endure
being like being a coke fiend I was your
mom 48 times my name people putting Coke
inside the [ __ ] casket she was
partying back then yeah she was party so
people were putting coke in time to
casket you don't know how many days I
sent that think of a bigger rock Oh like
one that I was like if I dig her up
she's got an ounce is still good I did
it's a little creepy green and and [ __ ]
using your razor blade to get the dirt
out of the car [ __ ] embarrassing god
please [ __ ] help me you know it's
just really weird Russell that I like to
tell you this to your face not one
person has ever said a bad word about
you but this is why I was important for
me to get you on the show and talk to
you a little bit you just get to know
you like I didn't I never wikipedia'd
you till today hell that was magic I've
heard that you pop up the places and DJ
yeah like I've heard this but I didn't
know for sure oh yeah yeah I thought you
would just [ __ ] copy and I was Ian's
arias I'm like that seems like a fake
[ __ ] I'm the first guy you're the
first guy and understand something I'd
get everything funded everything first
gods I was boxing from 85 to 90 for are
you really here
I was I was DJing from 85 till now I've
been doing comedy since 89 the boxing
amateur amateur you get beat up oh yeah
you love it done I loved it I had Lennox
Lewis and I were amateurs together
no we've been friends since like 86
about a very long time up there in
Canada yeah you've had a very
interesting yeah when I was home
recently I found a picture of me and
Lennox in like 96 or something cuz he
came to my show again couple weeks ago
knows in Toronto oh and but I found this
picture of him and I live so this is him
and I like blast what two weeks ago
right
Wow and then I found this picture of us
from like 96 and it's [ __ ] you guys
see the size of this guy's fist it's
ridiculous the reason why it was
everywhere champ literally made my you
know I don't have a small I got a pretty
big fist for a smaller guy I don't know
if I'm a smaller guy but look at the
size of his [ __ ] fist compared to
mine it's looking like I look like a
child
that was a long he was huge yeah he was
he and look I got a big fist yeah what
what's worse bombing or getting punched
in the face bombing oh my god [ __ ] it I
was not gonna be my guess some seven
years older than you
yeah so I'm musical tastes very similar
Emily from rock to disco love disco hip
hop to hip hop do you want did you watch
hip hop evolution on Netflix no just
documentary series is it good i
executive-produced it SOI we want a
Peabody and an Emmy for it well it's on
season two right now but it's four
episodes each season you'll love it
especially from being from the oh yeah
yeah it starts in 82
it starts in 72 that's when you trace it
back to yeah we go back to kool herc
coming to America from Jamaica and then
we go to when he threw the first party
at 15 15 15 20 seater Sedgwick Avenue in
the Bronx and that's what spawned hip
hop that night no [ __ ]
yeah you take it that deep we'll go
right to right right back because I was
right there for the disco hip-hop man
infusion did you go to studio 54 at the
end yeah
not well there was now Rodgers and I are
good friends okay
and I'm legal I'm not legally I'm
officially sheiks official DJ so
remember shake [ __ ] i DJ was a [ __ ]
soul chic [ __ ] oh yeah did intend today
I'm in the [ __ ] 8th grade I'm a
freshman maybe hmm
eighth grade freshman I'm a basketball
kid like I'm a basketball guy have me
beat already then
no but I was at good legs I can jump I
was a good rebound and he grabbed the
rim of the eighth grade
and I could barely dunk it my
neighborhood it was nine foot instead of
ten inches and that's had feet it was
nine feet ten inches right and I could
barely hit the ball I left my freshman
year like the hill off the rim I could
jump so I went to see my high school
against this hoboken just sensational
team in a ranked number two in the state
born in Camden forget about Camden
Camden was like [ __ ] everybody was
six foot eight already yeah can then
[ __ ] around they play down there by
Philly a that's a Philly they but yeah I
don't never forget that my high school
went into Hoboken and Hoboken the only
led the but when the county wins they
led the county and slam dunks in high
school they had a junior would have seen
him at that time this is 79 80 yeah what
is she she had come up 78 that's that's
the out yeah it might have been 77 even
North Bergen came out the wife you know
boy I was born a ramblin man yeah and
the lights went down also the Hoboken
came out to [ __ ] [ __ ]
doo-doo-doo did him the guy that was a
slam dunk I was juicy and he came out
with a tomahawk [ __ ] slam dunk ooh
tomahawk the high school nobody [ __ ]
time walked in high school in fact one
of the great covers of our time that
nobody talks about is a cover of uh I
can member his name of him or on Sports
Illustrated you know the time I Hawk is
trying to know when you come from I
can't even oh when you come from here
and go like that yeah overhead and
there's one of the one of the covers of
Sports Illustrated had it on my wall I
forget who the player was not dr. J no
it was a college basketball player he
was a [ __ ] college [ __ ] sensation
never went pro well yeah it was 78 77 he
was a Razorback his name was he was
hammered not an Arizona Razorback
but the other one [ __ ] you gotta see
this cover of him about the tomahawk
he's taking off and you can see the
players on a bench like getting up like
with their towels in their hand like no
he's not gonna do it
it's [ __ ] tremendous well anyway that
came out the chick she I didn't know
that you were friends with how long have
you been friends with [ __ ] cheek for
for Niall Niall and I have been friends
about uh say about eight years now then
how did you make your love music
industry oh yeah well he was a turned
out he was a fan and I was like what now
Rogers is a fan of Maya [ __ ] did that
happen that doesn't make sense to me I
bought every record this man did from
[ __ ] David Bowie to Madonna to Steve
Winwood to the b-52s everything he ever
did what they do Steve Winwood 83-85 he
did when you see a chance okay no no he
did higher love higher love and he did I
love who sang well hello Chuck okay
maybe I don't know I don't know how
shocked I was on that I went to go you
know so you found it oh no I'm looking
for I can't I'm nothing popping up yet
we do this thing where I have my
turntable set up with the band and now
stands in front of me and plays the
guitar lick for love freak so I'll show
you I'll show you the rehearsal video if
you wanna look for Razorbacks famous
Razorbacks okay
what's a Razorback what would winning I
don't know where the [ __ ] to the cocky
Arkansas Arkansas famous Arkansas
basketball plays and it'll tell you his
[ __ ] name what's Arkansas what are
they um where's our backs okay yeah
Razorbacks
so what the famous Razorback basketball
players from the 70s but Razorback from
Sports Illustrated cover why do you see
this here's Niall and I do in rehearsal
so he plays guitar for alle freak and I
scratched off guy below the microphone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look at this
Sidney Sid the squid Moncrief Mon cream
look at the people city look at the guy
with the brown shirt on it again with
the stripes looks like yeah looks like a
Frank Stallone look at that [ __ ] guy
I bumped into him at the airport once we
didn't like squid
no this is he wouldn't have to be a
[ __ ] tremendous pro but look at that
that's what 78 February was a 78 I can't
find in here February 13th yeah that's
when the that's what that tomahawk got
popularized with this one well that's
expensive back then a dollar for a
Sports Illustrated that's expensive you
got like it came out every week so you
got like fifty two copies for $48 you
gotta pay it up front one of money on
yeah I remember that I didn't even know
what a money order was you had to get
sport magazine was the other one so it
was sport and this so how long will you
DJ before you turn into Connolly um
three years four years before I started
doing comedy is amazing Russell I
thought you were doing comedy you
started like in 2000 no 89 I've been
without their banger hard road
good for you man the hard road I did
those [ __ ] gigs but I don't want to
see you you know I had all that [ __ ]
when people like you wanna go through
this room in time like I did that
already I'm good thanks
I don't need to [ __ ] relive my my my
[ __ ] painful moments not before you
hit were you coming to the stage laka
booka not much no 96 I came to New York
and uh I slept on Keith Robinson and
Patrice O'Neal's couch in Woodbridge New
Jersey and I remember they just [ __ ]
tore me apart I brought my special that
I shot in 95
Canada that was like a big hit in Canada
in 95 I brought it on VHS I was like
yeah check it out they watched it they
looked at me have to go the [ __ ] was
that
and I go what cuz I was [ __ ] and I'm
like why you can maybe been just being a
hater [ __ ] was trash what was so good
about it and I'm like damn they made me
rethink everything they made me get in
my head and made me made me work harder
if they didn't do that I wouldn't be
here today
I'd have been doing all the [ __ ]
mediocre [ __ ] I was doing where's our
special now I haven't seen it in years I
don't know where died probably exists
somewhere I have never never even seen
it online true or lose putting up your
good [ __ ] didn't get the badge mama
appreciate that thank God more [ __ ]
favor yeah right well they put the
second special on in 97 that was kind of
[ __ ] but whatever and how long were you
in New York fool that was about a month
month and a half at that time points
apiece O'Neal and those guys I met Keith
because he was shooting a movie in
Toronto that summer he was shooting the
movie called rebound the Earl Manigault
story and I ended up hanging out with
him and a bunch of other dudes and we
all became friends
I think keith was a comic and it's all
took from like 96th like 99 they would
shoot a lot of movies in Toronto yeah
then SARS hit and then it all ended then
it all ended
Nathan [ __ ] I'll move to Vancouver
that was crazy I remember going to
Bollywood and seen Bollywood I keep
calling it bollywood comedy would come
you're looking at me in picture in
Bollywood you said um I kept I kept
going to comedy wooden one time I was
there and I was outside for 10 minutes
and I saw three movie stars yeah it was
crazy back in the day actually Andy
Garcia
George Wendt and Angelina Jolie's father
gone into a hotel no yeah I remember I
was with um when 9/11 happened I was
with Mark Wahlberg and everybody appear
because it happened during the Toronto
Film Festival and if tell me see Mark
Wahlberg he never remembers me from that
day I'm like I was there two pivotal
Mark Wahlberg missed a flight he his
story was that he was supposed to go to
New York
that day or supposed to be on that
flight Austin but I'm like there's no
way you were supposed to be on that
flight from Boston cuz I was with you
the night before in Toronto yeah because
that was like big thing that he was
supposed to be on their flight yeah no
he wasn't he was in Toronto who's
already there I know with him the night
before I don't know them 9 10 I remember
I was running a beige shoe and it was
nice suit I don't know if he's been a
smartass or if he really liked the suit
but I really like the suit so I wonder
there's documentation that they had that
money for that plane ticket that was
just a [ __ ] lot it was been a little
exaggeration maybe if he wasn't in
Toronto he was supposed to be on that
flight or but no he was in Toronto then
I know cuz I was with him I got Taysom
well so you've had an interesting
[ __ ] Road amen I love it I'm happy
that you came on and talked a little bit
just I'm glad I keep watching and I keep
seeing the people who have on I go I
want to [ __ ] be on the church yeah I
wish I can have you for two with four
hours we'll do it I know that you have
that many [ __ ] stories yeah and now
you just do all these calm anytime
somebody bails I'll [ __ ] drive in now
you just do these [ __ ] to readers you
do whatever you don't even give it I
don't even care so when you do Oxnard
that's like that throwaway weekend yeah
it's just me getting back in shape you
know sparring doing new material no I'll
do my act still I want to tighten it up
I got to change it up now cuz when I
started the act in in February my life
changed so much from February to now
that I got a rewrite a lot of the Act I
mean it was started off I was sixteen
seventeen pounds heavier then so I was
like yeah I got fat no down back in
better shape down you know it started
off I was engaged well now I'm not
engaged you know I started off with I
didn't want any more kids in a fight and
I didn't want a son well now I've got a
pregnant girlfriend and I have a son
coming so I gotta [ __ ] rewrite the
one that was engaged no new girl you
moved that quick I may have been
double-dipping a little bit at least
you're honest you know you're very
honest can I just if I thought you it is
what it is you know yeah [ __ ] you you
lie you're gonna get found on them
people think you're alive
I'm from the era of video we award as
your word that's it that's it if I did
something wrong like I did saw you you
know you lied about why would I lie why
would I lie about so much yeah so many
[ __ ] better thinks the live button
I'm not going to only know about the
child congratulation thank chef our long
five months oh my god Roger you're a
savage and heat freak without warning
your appetite for love makes me so horny
yeah I've said in my head good I know
these lyrics
how great are those [ __ ] lyrics so
many good ones remember you know it's
fun song wasn't it rated X by Kool G Rap
greater than X but Kool G Rap or X rated
whatever it was called hard you know
we'll get you back on here with Dean doe
rain we'll smoke some pot yeah and
you'll have me and Dean the [ __ ]
sober I'll drink with you about that I
was I really want to hear about your
take on this hip hop I saw one take like
I didn't know about 1972 but I did know
about as soon as I heard I said hit the
message whatever the message well the
rapper's delight' for rapper's delight'
I was 79 that was 17 okay you know it's
funny about rappers it's in my it's in
if you get a chance and yes you don't
watch it on Netflix
yeah what's on the blade that's right
thing is in season one we talked of we
talked to Grandmaster Caz because they
stole Grandmaster Caz lyrics for
rapper's delight'
when big bank Hank says I'm the CAS a
that any ovy whatever the rest is f ly
Casanova fly he spells out [ __ ]
Grandmaster Caz his name I'm 6 foot 1
it's like you [ __ ] took my height
like you took everything that I said in
that song and used it for your own
purposes so they talked thick we talked
the Cavs because they were like they
stole the lyrics from him and they made
this huge song and then Mally mal who
Kaz and Mally mal er are like really
really close friends of mine and then it
cuts to melly-mel cos he was on Sugar
Hill Records
Grandmaster Flash diversified was signed
Sugar Hill Records and sylvia robinson
said to melly-mel
we need you guys to do a song like
rapper's delight' and then it
that's to melly-mel going we couldn't
make a piece of [ __ ] like that that's
why we did the message cuz I was like
I'm making no [ __ ] I'll make a real
[ __ ] song and then message was just
brilliant and then white lines and all
that [ __ ] that was all Mel that is crazy
but I'm living in New York you're in
there you're not mrs. Eddy copy are you
going the tunnel do you have to go to
the tunnel Latin Quarter I went to the
tunnel and I went the Latin Quarter but
I went to the tunnel that was a hole
light music joy hey you ever go to the
fever
I think the fever was in the Bronx no I
heard this disco fever disco fever I was
more of a Manhattan guy yeah you know
where wherever the cocaine was right
which was everywhere which was Chile
China [ __ ] but I saw the growth of that
music like I saw the growth of you know
going to the Bronx to cop coke mm-hmm a
special price and seeing guys in the
corner would turned it from the Mau Maus
in the Bronx the Puerto Ricans yeah like
seeing guys in the corner spit it yeah
and like taking the power from the light
pole you know going to the bodega and
get a bag of plantain chips huh don't
like a can of coke for the ride back to
Jersey yeah but being mesmerized by this
thing and then it was black guys rapping
on the corner yeah like I saw that
happening and I saw guys you'd go to cop
in the Brooklyn awesome they'd have a
linoleum floor mm-hmm they'd come up
with had my used to breakdance I have my
little I couldn't afford linoleum so if
I would draw walk around my neighborhood
and see if somebody bought a fridge or a
stove and I would steal a cardboard box
and take it home when they were throw it
out you know the evolution you know a
couple days ago somebody said well you
guys seen the growth here with the
medical marijuana
I saw the growth with the music and I
saw the growth of marijuana
get replace by crack cocaine yeah that
quick like it overstepped the powder
like forget the powder we were right
from marijuana to crack cocaine yeah so
it was all an evolution all at the same
time again Grandmaster Caz tells me
about he was on
for ten years he told me he said he
doesn't know how to [ __ ] he survived
that [ __ ] he doesn't know how he never
got aids from that [ __ ] cause he'd be
[ __ ] crackhead [ __ ] in like in the
crack houses I mean he was like I don't
know how to [ __ ] I never got nothing I
don't know you don't know what life is
so you walked into a crack house oh yeah
he was tell me off away then one one
night the cop like I wouldn't the city
the table all [ __ ] up
mm-hm and why soon as I got to the
building as I go up the corner
they got raided she went up the corner I
think I have to call it was my name is
like Flaco you know they all had Blanco
and or whatever if you want what do you
want you know yeah and I told the guy go
I'm just not giving you cash I gotta go
upstairs for him so we went and it was
like we went through a good building to
go into this [ __ ] den of [ __ ]
death and he thinks stinks you could
smell piss yeah and man they had a B
this is 1984 they had to be like nine
people in corner that looked at me like
I was a [ __ ] top just smoking
whatever like a pipe and it was a [ __ ]
they were doing it that time yeah and
then there was a guy there that would
sell the coat though there was a guy
that would stay there all night with
like three bodyguards and I've been
going in there at [ __ ] for the
morning and buying maybe an ounce and a
half of coke from him it's a lot of coke
him searching me and [ __ ] asking me if I
was a cop and I started talking Spanish
to one of the guys they know is the cop
but that's the first and only time I saw
a real crack yeah my friend's father was
a crackhead in the 80s it was a trip
dude we go to his house and you could
tell when his dad was rocked out cuz
you'd be like well you cook up good and
strong get us some [ __ ] chicken
there's talking lock jawed like a
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you doing
totally it you're gonna [ __ ] him or
gonna grow some chicken
god damn I remember going I sleeping
over I sleep on his couch I woke up in
the middle of night one day to go to
take a piss I go in the bathroom his
dad's in there with a chick and some
dude in the shooting up heroin in the
bathroom like I hope this dog
struggle back-to-back over 14 just tell
your parents like we're not gonna I'm
not gonna stop with your own little
[ __ ] treasure chest
sounds like wow I've never seen that
[ __ ] before oh my god Russell you have a
real deal bid map you took the time
whether you guys show tonight I gotta be
down there - you're on yeah then I'm
nice 25 that's a hell of a lineup - yeah
it's gonna be great
that's you need a right no it's crazy
because you said something before I shot
the left leg special I was [ __ ] around
I was [ __ ] around Russell and I went
to other places and then as soon as I
finished shooting and I got on the plane
I said I [ __ ] up I'm not calling the
story mm-hmm because I took the easy
route right it's still goin to the
stormy night banging a lot you go to the
store five nights a week for six weeks
you come out of that animal tower I
don't you wanna go up at midnight - yeah
just tell Hannah morning over the middle
and everything you come out an animal
yeah they might be able to that's what
I'm doing next time I got a special
offer today you gotta go you're gonna
run the belly of the beast
I'm gonna the belly of the beast
changing it all up different training
regimen I trained wrong and that's why
now I just only go to Academy store I
only go on without me yeah I don't ever
see nowhere else that's it that there's
no reason to anymore anywhere else I go
and I just get depressed so why am I
gonna be there the home comley's my I
don't want to always perform like I do
at the county store I have to always be
in that state of mind when I don't
economy so it's to kill somebody it's
ahead I love watching it's to kill
survive when I go over that hill in
Laurel Canyon oh listen to the radio I
just go deep deep deep into my thoughts
and I think about getting beat up I
think about mugging people I think about
bad [ __ ] I think about good should I
laugh at him I'm gonna fly them came out
of his bag last night I go through a bag
of emotions on Laurel Kane so when I get
to the store it's like [ __ ] I know I'm
on my I met that gym with Muhammad Ali
went with Angelo Dundee trying mom my
way no was Miami
that was a 414 gym or something like
that you know that's way
- Street Jimmy I was that's what it was
today I was at the pool yeah and they
called me from the store she goes you
have a 10:45 spot hello are you doing
the lor original well if I go down there
at 9:00 crippled who put you out no yeah
if we then come on you know I was going
through the Twitter ID I was at the pool
with my daughter and I looked at the
lineup grande white Chris D'Elia
Whitney Joe and I'm all of this line up
and I'm like I'm [ __ ] 55 I'm saying
yeah like I'm 55 years old and I'm still
on these [ __ ] line ups
I like that like emotional that's why
crying you know you know who's that you
know else is a good person to uh for
that is and that appreciates the game
still and he's been in it forever as Dom
yeah you have to appreciate any comments
the best Dom has I don't think Dom has a
[ __ ] bitter bone in his body
you shouldn't he's so amazing when I got
here I all I talked through a bit
acrylics oh yeah so I like to water
myself I would not become that person
this is a gamble if you give it the best
you got
if you know you're giving it the best
you got
it'll give it back to you he'll give it
back to you if you're [ __ ] around
your ain't gonna get dick yeah but if
you give it if you go all the [ __ ]
it'll give back to you and then you
won't have any regrets you know when you
work be rooms and see rooms on the road
if you work a little better la salle are
you ever better everybody gay you got a
know Pete I know the worst is the club
owners they're like yeah you know you're
in [ __ ] Wichita and they're like
trying to act like they know comedy
better than you like yeah no come on
it's good to eat you're the [ __ ] one
a stick co staying out here and I mean
don't don't [ __ ] look at me like I'm
the jerk off it's so weird how I'm very
happy about one thing now when it comes
to my career that I just stick to my
were like I don't break light anything
like this is how it is this is how we're
doing it and that said no questions if
we can't do it that way then let me know
I will find a weekend when I can do it
that way yeah and they'll change their
tune right away like I love you know I
don't bully am I'm not a bad person
but I explained them this is how we're
doing and if we don't do it this way
then that's fine like I love when they
call me we can't bring a feature we
already I'm okay no worry cancel the
week let me know what I can remember you
let me tell you when I can bring my
future and then they call you back okay
it was a misunderstanding that's always
what it is a miss yes when I oh that's
my favorite thing to hear Ron I know you
gotta go I love you I love you Joey can
they go find you Russell Peters calm at
Russell Peters on Instagram it was a
real pleasure having you you know you're
uh you're a champion in and out of the
[ __ ] ring in my eyes and now that we
cleared that air up I will be up to do a
private session with you I'm training
tomorrow if you're in
I got a 1:30 not tomorrow and I got nine
10:30 and 12:30 tomorrow and then four
o'clock karate and tomorrow night's
pizza night because I'm leaving Thursday
we do this easy tomorrow on the last two
days I've been running yeah let me know
when you're back yeah you got some time
off in December yes they lifted it I
went to Muay Thai nice I've got a Muay
Thai at 9:00 and they're gonna be tight
conditioning to get out of the way I'm
55 yeah you know I get it I can't
I don't know time to wait till 6 o'clock
to do [ __ ] rolls yeah you got me
early you gotta get me early yeah 8
o'clock I can't roll 9 o'clock I can't
roll it's a little early to roll yeah
but 10:00 10:30 I could roll I roll at
1:30 I feel good about the role that
1:30 is good I like a boy roll an empty
stomach
yes sir why I don't eat well out there
stomach that's when I do my best when
I'm hungry and I end up farting if I
[ __ ] roll with all I love when people
get on top of me and I blow a fart and
then I try to sweep them when they get a
whiff of that [ __ ] far and [ __ ]
and they they go for it if I can't sweep
you once I thought you're going down you
know Rico Rodriguez yeah oh my god I
wrote that brother I hurled with Rico
one day about a year ago and I wrote
with John Jack for an hour and then at
the end of the session Rico was there
and as make a fun a Rico at the
beginning of the class out loud not to
myself just I was like in a prick in his
balls in front of the cords he's big
it's a big [ __ ] he's big former UFC hey
you know what was he big like oh he's a
little smaller saw him on Saturdays a
little walk but
piggy he gets big and not fat either
like yeah it's big so III and then John
Tucker do you want to roll somebody else
ago yeah sure he goes hey Rico and I got
a [ __ ] I was a white belt at the time
too so he calls Rico I coach it so you
know you shake your hands and I just
pull guard right away because I'm like
I'm not trying to fight I'm not trying
to get thrown around this this gym so I
just pull grabbed his gay and his wrist
and then pulled guard right away he's on
top of me just stands up he starts
pushing down on me you know and my neck
is on the ground oh my god [ __ ] and he's
holding me and then my body decided to
release whatever air it had left in it
and I sharted I [ __ ] myself happened no
I told her go Rico I just [ __ ] he goes
ha ha ha that's funny I go no I'm
seriously [ __ ] myself he's laughing and
I a couple of seconds I was like the
[ __ ] is that smell I told you I just
[ __ ] myself go Rico you literally beat
the [ __ ] out of me I've never shipped
myself but I've come close it can't run
in the house when they get on top he and
mount oh man and you try to do that too
time oppa anything going nowhere and
you're mounted and they're creeping up
like a snake and their ass is pushing on
every wall getting together yeah it's a
the masters of that yeah once you get
over brown belt yeah you know how to
torture people it's called invisible
jiu-jitsu that's Rick's insulations
thing visible jiu-jitsu is the worst
yeah they don't even do enough to tell
you and it's just way that it's like
John John here John jocks mount you're
in no danger like you're in no danger
once he mounts you
he always says if somebody passes you
God you messed up two steps ago yeah
isn't that things he'll do this he'll
just he'll get on top but give me sick
gifts I control on me and then he'll go
okay let's see how you deal with this
and then all of a sudden you just feel
like a [ __ ] anvil landed on your what
the [ __ ] is that
you're 175 pounds how did this happen
they know exactly how to [ __ ] you yeah
and he'll do what you like okay you
can't breathe up here now you can't
breathe down there now you can't breathe
up here and you'll just keep shifting it
so that my breathing gets [ __ ] up it's
[ __ ] crazy it's insane how good he's
like a [ __ ] Jedi I love you brother
you too bro thank you very much for
taking the time
your family knock them dead at the store
I'll see the sees all that I want to
take my man Russell Peters I want to
take my men that Christ killed but most
importantly I want to thank you guys for
supporting me and have my back Portland
I'm coming but the tickets are sold out
and next weekend I'm in La Jolla and
their tickets are sold out - it's a
small joint I'm just trying to work on
new stuff you know you know how we do it
here but there's still tickets available
December 12th for the temblor Brewing
Company up in [ __ ] Bakersfield up
there at Matt bacon territory up there
and true blue BJJ not [ __ ] around so
I'll be up there Wednesday December 12th
at 8 o'clock the temblor and then I got
Oxnard after the holidays what we'll
talk to that down a little later
the Lebanese live up in Oxnard that's it
and that's done it's been a great week I
want to thank Anthony cool me for coming
on
I want to thank Russell Peters but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] in the church family for
having our back it's that time of the
year where you might be getting down and
we're here to [ __ ] save your life
never fear uncle Joey's here all right
don't forget what I got to say also this
podcast is brought to you by quipped
when you think of a perfect gift you
probably don't think of an electric
toothbrush but the crippled electric
toothbrush is one of the most gift
guided gifts of the season and here's
why it's perfect for everybody with a
mouth and if they say something if it's
something they'll use twice every day
that's why they're gonna use your gift
this is not a tie this is not a wallet
let me tell you something ever since
I've been working with equipment been
using that toothbrush being my wife and
the baby we love it as a little timer it
tells you on the switch and it's very
easy to take it on the road that's what
makes it that's why I love it the most
clip is the gift that keeps refreshing
with brush heads that automatically
delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just $5
and you could even get prepaid refills
for a year to make sure they're never
gonna be
never gonna be old or worn out or
ineffective bristles clip is one of the
first electric toothbrushes accepted by
the American Dental Association and has
a thousands of
verified five-star review you know why I
love quit for the reasons why I told you
and because it makes a great gift it's
portable it's clean it does a tremendous
job and your mouth feels tremendous
after you use equipment so what I'm
gonna do is this all right why are we
playing games for equip has over five
star over 5000 verified five-star
reviews quick looks like a big ticket
tech gift with the stocking stuffer
price starting at just $25 and if you go
to get quick calm right now / Joey get
quick calm / Joey right now you get your
first refill packed for free with equip
electric toothbrush but you don't have
to tell you give to you that that's your
first refill pack for free at get quick
calm slash Joey listen it's about
toothbrush it's the best best to
electric toothbrush out there and if you
travel this is the one for you going to
get quick comm slash Joey I also the
podcast of life is brought to you by my
favorite people in the world
hello [ __ ] until she all right listen
why walk around with a mildew infected
[ __ ] when you could be ready for
[ __ ] action you want your muffle to
be clean you want to save the [ __ ]
planet you want them to stop cutting
down trees you want your ass to dry
naturally you get yourself one of those
little [ __ ] Arabian towels right
there from hello to she and you dry you
a little muffle if you want to squirt it
with some soap I'm sure you use some
like and deodorize or whatever just to
keep it real nice and sparkly and I'm
saying but it all starts by you gonna
helmet pushy calm right now take a look
at the portable days they had them in
all colors all different sizes of you on
hot water cold water and they started
$69 that's a [ __ ] Christmas present
you ever look at your mother and go I
wonder what ever a so smells like you're
gonna leave your mother to say that this
is the time to take care of that go -
hello - she's calm right now and press
in muffler and get 10% off your order
all right I want to thank
again I want to thank hello tushy I want
to thank on it I want to thank Fuji
sports calm I want to thank you
[ __ ] for being part of the
church family and for keeping us going
every week week after [ __ ] week I
love you guys I'll see you Monday
morning or I'll see you this weekend in
Portland
bring the [ __ ] reefer well if not
I'll see the rest of you guys Monday
morning tip-top Magoo ready to go I love
you guys stay black check this [ __ ]
meal Lee